the world battles coronavirus as the
United States enters in your total
lockdown the Trump administration lays
out what the future holds and Bernie and
Biden hit each other with their walkers
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show today's show is sponsored by
expressive VPN protect your data from
prying eyes and expressive VPN dot-com
/ban while we're all still here guys can
be okay as I said last Friday it's gonna
be okay we just have to do what we have
to do and that mainly means stay at home
make sure that your family is taken care
of here's a few things for you to do
today here's what I'm gonna try and do
today anyway if I'm a good person when
I'm gonna trying to take a few things
first call five friends find out how
they're doing at social distancing means
that we are not allowed as human beings
to do all the things that we actually
usually do in times of crisis usually
when there's a time of crisis you get
together with friends usually get
together with your religious community
now we have this very odd circumstance
where we're being encouraged to stay
away from all of our friends and from
our local community this does increase
loneliness it does increase feelings of
angst obviously everybody's very nervous
this obviously at the back of
everybody's mind but here are a few
things that we can do first call five
friends you got a phone call a friend
use use FaceTime do something to reach
out to five people just find out how
they're doing today find out if an
elderly neighbor or relative needs any
grocery or pharmacy Goods and bring them
over have you got somebody in your
family who's over the age of 65 make
sure that they're actually stocked up if
they're not stocked up and you are young
go buy the groceries for them bring them
to them as supply lines are still in
place there may be some temporary
shortages of some goods that will
alleviate as time goes on also go out to
a local store call a local store would
be even better call a local store and
buy a gift card you know that you're
gonna use that gift card later and right
now everybody's in a cash crunch so many
stores are shutting down
now I personally know people who run
small businesses and they are seeing
their business basically be destroyed by
coronavirus because they're operating on
slim margins they're trying to keep
people paid well if you know you're
gonna buy from the store later and you
just can't go to the store right now
because the store is closed instead buy
a gift card give gift cards to your
friends if you've got the expendable
cash to do so and just make clear to
those businesses that you're gonna keep
patronizing the business and give them
the temporary float of basically paying
them upfront buy a gift card from a
local store for later use it'll help
tide them over and finally go for a walk
look seriously turn off
the news turn off Twitter go for a walk
don't hang out with people who are
walking with you you know social
distancing and all that but get outside
look at the sky it still exists look at
the Sun it still exists the temptation
is obviously to be sort of stuck in your
house but just because we are supposed
to self isolate sort of does not mean
that we can't engage with the world
around us and there is something
inherently optimistic about going
outside for a walk so here are a few
tips for today now I want to start off
today by giving some actual information
on Chronicle Roggin as always we do this
on the show always anyway we start off
with information and then we get to the
opinion of it all some useful
information for you about coronavirus so
right now one of the biggest problems
with coronavirus is we actually don't
know all that much about it most people
don't know the symptoms they feel like
okay if I if my nose starts to run if I
have a dry cough does this mean that I
have coronavirus the answer is in all
likelihood no you probably just have
allergies right it's the middle of March
the chances are very high they just have
a normal cold or you have allergies so
there's a good article in The New York
Times today by a woman in new vol shake
talking about the differences between
coronavirus and allergies and what you
should be looking for and this is good
to know because honestly it's hard not
to go to the most paranoid place you
start feeling a little bit ill and
you're like oh my god I've got
coronavirus you know I've infected the
entire planet my entire family is at
risk here are the symptoms that you
should be looking for you have to
consider the time of year according to
the New York Times allergies and
influenza tend to be seasonal if you
have a runny nose in the spring and this
happens every year allergies are the
likeliest culprit you may have noticed
last week that I had bit of a cough I
knew it wasn't coronavirus coz I got a
cough literally this time every single
year plus I had fasted plus I'm not
sleeping because of the new baby if it's
winter and flu is raging in your
community then that is the probable
explanation the flu is far more
widespread than corona virus if you have
flu-like symptoms in warm and weather in
a place with documents a corona virus
transmission then maybe it's not the flu
influenza does tend to tie back in the
summer we don't know yet whether corona
virus is going to do the same thing
especially because as the Times points
out there have been corona virus
infections spreading in place like
Singapore and in the southern hemisphere
which are currently experiencing summer
temperatures also consider where the
symptoms first started appearing
according to one doctor it's usually
your nose and eyes where you develop
symptoms of seasonal allergies the
seasonal flu is more likely to affect
your whole body as is the case for many
other respiratory viruses including a
corona virus so if you have a fever
headache muscle aches then you should
become
whether it's flu or coronavirus if
instead you're just getting you know
runny nose itchy eyes then all
likelihood you just have allergies or
maybe you just have a cold it's hard to
tell the difference team flew and
coronavirus but the difference you know
cold and a flu we all know and so if it
feels more like a cold then it feels
like the flu the chances that you
actually have corona virus really really
slim so there's a little bit of
information for you also not very many
people are experiencing nausea or
vomiting about five percent of patients
with kronos only four percent are
developing diarrhea so those are
symptoms sort of more typical flu so
fever would be the first one right this
is why everybody's being tested for
fever body aches fever chills right that
would be the stuff where you start to
worry even then only if it starts to get
bad enough that you're starting to have
shortness of breath should you really
consider going in for a test according
to the New York Times pay close
attention to whether your symptoms
worsen over time discomfort due to
allergy remains consistent until you
treat it or the allergy goes away
symptoms of the flu tend to resolve in
about a week but the new corona virus
seems to cause more severe symptoms than
the average seasonal flu seems to have a
higher fatality rate if you're elderly
of other health conditions and obviously
you got to be quicker to get a test if
you are younger and you're experiencing
this sort of stuff then you're probably
supposed to stay home unless it gets a
little bit more severe mild cases of the
flu resolved by themselves within a few
days corona virus tends to last a little
bit longer but most people with mild
cases tend to get better in about two
weeks so there's a little bit of
information for you if you're not
feeling great today then think about
that description of symptoms and see
sort of which one it fits okay in just a
second I'm gonna give you some
information on where we currently stand
in terms of the total number of case
counts and it's kind of fascinating to
see how this thing has leveled off in
China while it continues to grow fairly
exponentially in Italy also we're going
to talk about the different strategies
the countries have been using to deal
with corona virus because there's a sort
of fascinating from a data perspective
social experiment currently taking place
between the United States and the UK
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
you're losing your hair right now like
I'm moving my hair I mean who's that
losing their hair thinking about the
possibility of Stephen King's The Stand
becoming reality well if you prefer not
to lose your hair then maybe you should
think about keeps because the fact is
once the hair has gone very difficult to
regrow two out of three dudes will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 with
today's advancements in science keeps
offers proven treatments that can combat
the
symptoms of hair loss keep and help you
keep the hair that you have at half the
cost of your local pharmacy prevention
is indeed key keep stuff to 90%
effective at reducing and stopping
further hair loss the sooner you start
using keeps the more hair you will save
so act fast Plus keeps is now offering a
prescription shampoo to keep your scalp
healthy as well and these are all FDA
approved products I've been using keeps
myself because her male pattern baldness
runs in my family if you're ready to
take action prevent hair loss head on
over to keeps calm so I've been to
receive your first month of treatment
for free that is ke EPS calm /ban again
that is keeps calm / men and get your
first month of treatment for fruits a
pretty solid deal and again everything
being delivered directly to your door
it's that time in the world getting
things delivered to your door really
convenient you still need that
medication goto keeps calm / man ke EPS
calm / been okay so here are the total
number of coronavirus cases by country
right now this is according to the Johns
Hopkins study there Johns Hopkins has a
really good chart of all of this china's
basically leveled off they've eighty
1000 cases in china they've had eighty
1000 cases in china for the last several
weeks that is because they locked down
basically 700 million people one of the
benefits of being in authoritarianism
one of the downsides of being an
authoritarian country as you wait two
months to do it and then try to shoot
everybody who talks about it so that's
the downside the upside is that
eventually you go full authoritarianism
Italy is the country that is
experiencing significant problems Italy
obviously now has twenty four thousand
seven hundred forty-seven documented
cases with eighteen hundred and nine
documented deaths again it's very
difficult to tell what the actual death
rates here are because it does all
reliance on who exactly is getting
tested and if only the most severe
people are getting tested because you
have a shortage of tests right only the
most severe are encouraged to go get
tested obviously that's gonna be
elevated death rates so there have only
been twenty five thousand actual
confirmed cases in Italy the chances are
very high that a lot more people than
that have actually obtained
coronavirus in Italy but they had 368
people died of korenev iris just
yesterday so obviously they have
exponential growth in Italy Iran we have
no idea what the actual numbers are
they're saying 15 thousand infected in
Iran with nearly a thousand deaths 853
total deaths according to Johns Hopkins
but the numbers are likely to be much
higher because again repressive
dictatorships have an incentive to lie
about their actual numbers Spain
seeing exponential death Spain has 900
9407 documents in cases with 335 total
deaths there are 530 people recovered
now as time goes on the numbers have
recovered are going to increase pretty
radically too because the number of
people in hospitals who are finally
being released it takes a little while
for people who even enter a hospital to
be released South Korea has really
leveled this thing off they've only had
75 total deaths in South Korea and the
total number of documented cases is 80
236 that is because South Korea took
significant social distancing measures
they've really cracked down the shut
down large places of business very early
on Germany is seeing a rapid increase in
the number of actual cases but very few
actual deaths so Germany has 6672 actual
cases only 14 deaths so far which is
kind of fascinating there have been some
theories as to why things are going so
wrong in Italy but so right in Germany
and one of the theories is that there is
a lot of cross generational pollination
and Italy people tend to hang out with
older relatives in Italy a lot more
often than they do in Germany and this
does lead to some serious questions
about the measures that are being taken
in the West right now by the way France
has about fifty four hundred cases 127
total deaths the United States right now
has 69 total deaths and 3,800 documented
cases so that is where things stand on a
country-by-country level and the the
fascinating thing is seeing how
different countries respond to all of
this obviously Italy has locked
everything down but they did it late the
United States is currently locking
everything down in my home city of Los
Angeles
everything has basically been locked
down Mayor Eric Garcetti who couldn't
lock down 65,000 homeless people in the
city so presumably those people who are
wandering around and are absolutely risk
factors for coronavirus you a bunch of
people who are living on streets who are
in no sense clean I mean they homeless
people are not famous for showering very
often or or up keeping with the sort of
personal how are they washing their
hands Wow hand-washing going on the
homeless community here in Los Angeles
living in areas that are extremely dirty
if 65,000 homeless people in LA County
alone that has not been locked down for
years and was basically facilitated by
the LA city government people were being
told their stuff couldn't be moved
people were being told it was fine for
them to sleep on the street so all of
that is fine but Mayor Eric Garcetti is
locking down the entire city of Los
Angeles he announced this last night I
signed an order tonight that will
the following it prevents people from
gathering in close proximity by banning
and closing our bars and nightclubs
second restaurants and retail facilities
we will now have prohibited on-site food
but permitted for delivery take out and
drive-through groceries pharmacies and
food banks are of course exempt from
this order of closure movie theaters
though performance venues bowling alleys
arcades gyms and fitness centers will be
closed to the public okay so there is no
end date on all of this as far as
garcetti is concerned in reality I can't
see this thing lasting for weeks on end
and the idea that you're gonna shut down
the entire American economy and this is
happening in New York too they're gonna
see a shutdown of the entire American
economy for months on end I mean I
honestly don't know how people of the
West are going to respond to that sort
of thing particularly if the data coming
out from the UK is wildly different
first of all I'm not sure how any of
this is enforceable I mean what are
gonna station a cop at every bowling
alley in the United States in a station
a cop in every restaurant okay the fact
is that right now people are gonna deal
with it because these restaurants will
still have heavy levels of takeout
orders and my family is still gonna get
takeout for sure but how exactly do you
police that I mean if the local
restaurant has people who are coming in
and picking up food how are you gonna
stop somebody from sitting down at a
table and eating is there gonna be a cop
there who's just gonna haul everybody
off to jail how exactly is that going
work we've seen something similar happen
in New York City where Bill DeBlasio
went to the gym this morning one said
YMCA this one has a man is a he's
shutting down all of these restaurants
in the same way that Garcetti is by the
way people in the United States some
some are taking this seriously some
people really are not there were
pictures from Disney World last night
where it was completely packed no
Disneyland and Disney World I believe
are shutting down but completely packed
Bourbon Street there were cops out in
the streets last night having to remind
people guys like there's a pandemic on
go home what is the police authority in
the sort of situation are they actually
gonna start arresting people on mass who
don't have coronavirus we have not yet
seen the consequences of that the truth
is that voluntary civil society has done
a fairly good job of locking this down
so far putting the prospect of
government compulsion on the table in a
way where the government can't actually
enforce that may carry some of its own
consequences it's unclear exactly how
he plans to enforce any of this at all
nonetheless as we see the measures that
are being taken are wildly wildly
different across across countries in the
United States the CDC is now
recommending no gatherings of 50 people
or more for eight weeks for eight weeks
which Wow Wow I mean I failed to see
honestly how they don't start putting
restrictions on air travel if that is if
that is the actual risk if what we are
being told is that gatherings of 50
people or more are basically verboten in
the United States and the people should
not gather and in numbers and why 50 why
not 15 or 20 I mean basically they're
saying it shouldn't even be 15 or 20
they're basically saying stay in your
home how do you say to people stay in
your home for two months for two months
I mean based on the risk factors that we
have seen thus far
I understand exponential growth I
explained it last week on the show I
understand geometric growth right we
explained it last week on the show we
understand the risk factors the question
is how long can a society afford to be
in complete lockdown and how long can
the the US government take on debt
without eventually people saying this is
the new normal and the economy
completely collapsing right now
everybody is sort of assuming that this
thing comes to an end in eight weeks or
six weeks or twelve weeks or whatever it
is as long as we know what the actual
end time is like when this thing
actually comes to a stop then we know
when the recovery begins but if this
becomes an indefinite suspension and
we're all just supposed to stay home how
long can the government just continue to
keep paying people based on what based
on the prospect of future growth if
there is no prospect of future growth
that's why you said the markets tanked
this morning we'll get to that in just a
little while but first let us talk about
how right now if you are looking to save
money on your business which everyone
pretty much is you need to be using
LegalZoom hourly legal fees will
absolutely kill your business it is one
of the reasons why you should be looking
to LegalZoom for a lot of your different
forms for all for all of the ways that
you have legal questions taxes is one
thing we know we all have to deal with
this time of year as a business owner
it's critical to know all their options
and that's why you should lean on
LegalZoom LLC's DBAs escorts they all
mean different things when it comes to
paying taxes and limiting your personal
liability there's a lot to think about
if you are thinking about opening the
doors on a business or even prepping to
open in doors on a business or taking
care of your current business for
reorganization purposes with Legal Zoom
you don't have to worry about doing all
the legwork yourself to find the right
answers
they have a ton of resources to help
including their network of Independence
attorneys and tax professionals they'll
provide the advice you need to ensure
you're operating your business the way
you want to since Legal Zoom is not a
law firm you'll save time and money
while avoiding hourly fees whether you
need to incorporate form an LLC or set
up your business another way use Legal
Zoom to maximize your business's
potential and make your accountant happy
go to legalzoom.com today to get your
business on the right track for 2020
Legal Zoom is where life meets the gummy
using Legal Zoom for years long before
they're an advertiser on the program you
should too why spend hundreds of bucks
an hour on lawyers when you could do it
yourself using Legal Zoom check them out
at legalzoom.com
today and get on the right track for
what is bound to be a volatile year
legalzoom.com go check them out right
now so as I say the cdc has now
recommended that no gatherings with 50
people or more be held in the united
states for the next eight weeks which
basically means the end of all sporting
events all movies all entertainment
industry events it means the end of
going to church in any sort of large
numbers or synagogue and any sort of
large numbers the cdc does not apply
this to the day-to-day operation of
organizations like schools Institute's
of higher learning or businesses and
added it was not intended to supersede
the advice of local health officials
it's hard to see how the schools remain
open under those circumstances I mean
schools everywhere are closing my kids
were let off at the end of last week
LAUSD was let off at the end of last
week the New York school districts have
now all been led off schools across the
country are being closed for this thing
and that is I would assume all the way
until the summer at this point it is
March if you're assuming eight weeks
that takes you the middle of May so at
that point there's no point right I mean
now summer has happened so so there's no
reason to go back to school the CDC says
the recommendation is made in an attempt
to reduce introduction of the virus into
new communities and to slow the slow the
spread of infection communities already
affected by the virus the CDC urged
people to take care with even small
gatherings they said events of any size
should be continued if they can own only
if they can be carried out with
adherence to guidelines for protecting
vulnerable populations hand hygiene and
social distancing when feasible
organisers should modify events to be
virtual as well so basically the end of
social life in America as we know at
California the state has already told
the residence 65 and older to stay home
completely they are now calling for
everybody above the age of 65 to shelter
in their homes Massachusetts is already
moving to ban dining in bars and
restaurants beginning on Tuesday
effectively
closing Boston's bars for Saint Patrick
Patrick stay Puerto Rico and setting
some strict measures in the United
States imposing a 9:00 p.m. to 5:00 a.m.
curfew and closing non-essential
businesses gavin newsom said we're
calling for the home isolation of all
seniors in california so really strict
steps being taken meanwhile as I say the
fascinating sort of counterexample is
what the UK is doing right that's the
fascinating counterexample and and this
is really the way that we're gonna be
able to tell whether all of this is an
overreaction in terms what we are doing
about it or whether the UK has just
blatantly screwed this thing up and a
lot of people are gonna die because the
UK is screwing this thing up according
to the Financial Times the UK is
basically asking everybody over 70 to
self isolate for up to four months and
then they're saying everybody else go
out and do what you want and the reason
they're saying that is they're saying
listen there is a vast difference in the
vulnerability of older populations
people with pre-existing conditions and
people who are younger and it's actually
not good to have people who are younger
destroying the economy of your country
by staying home in order to protect
people who you can protect by simply
having them basically self quarantine
right have everybody who's in the
vulnerable population stay home have
everybody else go to work and then if
all those people infect each other and
then of all those people experience mild
symptoms and then if they spend two
weeks being a little bit sick and
they're saying by the way if you have a
cough or you have a fever then go home
and self quarantine for a week and you
do all of that sort of stuff then in a
few months there will be a herd immunity
that's sort of the theory that is
ongoing in the UK and it'll be
fascinating I mean if they have the same
death rates as as the United States or
South Korea or China or even Italy then
the question is going to be did we just
destroy the entire world economy for
several months on end in order to
protect a vulnerable population when the
vulnerable population could have been
protected simply by having them shelter
in place according to Financial Times
the UK government will ask everyone aged
over 70 to self isolate from two four
months has called on manufacturers to
increase production of ventilators Matt
Hancock is the health secretary and said
the elderly would be asked to take
measures to protect themselves from the
virus in the coming weeks he said that
the corona virus would disrupt the lives
of almost everybody in the UK the
question and you're seeing kind of panic
messages coming out of companies and
coming out of public health officials
the question is whether that is based on
data or whether that is based on the
sheer sense that if we don't do
something and do something right now
that this thing could rage
out of control so how much of that is
realistic again we're now in the
forecasting business because here's the
thing if you take these really heavy
measures and things don't get really bad
then you get to say it was the heavy
measures that prevents the things from
getting really bad if you don't take to
haveyou measures and things get really
bad people go why the hell didn't you
take the heavy measures if you don't
take the heavy measures and things end
up being pretty good then everybody says
why the hell did you take the really
heavy measures in the first place so the
sort of safety safest thing to do as a
public leader I've been saying this
about president Trump for a while the
safest thing to do as a public leader is
to overreact what's the worst that
happens that you overreact and then
there's less death and then you say
right there was less death because I
overreacted
there's no counterfactual UK right now
is providing a counterfactual so it'll
be fascinating to see whether that
counterfactual actually results in the
same sort of death rates as in the
United States the number of people
diagnosed with Kovan 19 in the UK has
now reached 1372 the number of deaths
has hit 35 all of the deaths have been
among those with underlying health
conditions are aged over 60 appearing on
the Andrew Marr show on the BBC Hancock
said the government would introduce
emergency legislation through the House
of Commons next week to give the
authorities the powers they need to
force people to self isolate Hancock
also said he could not rule out closing
non-essential businesses like
restaurants and bars said we haven't
ruled that out we'll do whatever is
necessary but the but the sort of
differentiation between the age groups
here again it provides a fascinating
counterfactual to the u.s. reaction
which is basically been on the order of
South Korea or China and yes we are
reacting faster than the Chinese did we
are reacting much faster than the
Italians did right the Italians only
started closing things down at day 15
since when this stuff started appearing
in their country we've closed everything
down day 10 day 11 now this is gonna
have significant Retro significant
ramifications for the economy of course
and and that is why the Fed is now
moving to lower the interest rates you
know that will get to the financial
ramifications of this for just saying
but first a note of a note of optimism
now everybody is kind of looking at the
empty shelves right now and freaking out
but the supply chain to remain strong
what's happening right now is you're
seeing the first wave of sort of panic
buying people going out there and trying
to stock up listen I get it I've got a
family I want to make I'll be honest
with you I told my wife two weeks ago to
go and stock up as soon as this stuff
started hitting the united states i said
listen i think there's gonna be a
problem
go and stock up so our fridge
is full for people who are not there
panic buying right now but don't worry
that stuff will be restocked all the
idiots out there who are saying things
like this is what a capitalist economy
looks like in times of crisis yeah and
this is what a socialist economy looks
like all the time the difference is that
there's gonna be milk on the shelves
tomorrow morning thanks to capitalism
there will there will be Purell back on
the shelves this week thanks to thanks
to capitalism I thank God for capitalism
thank God for supply chains thank God
for free markets the new york times is
reporting the aisles and aisles of empty
store shelves give the appearance the
united states is running out of food but
the nation's biggest retailers dairy
farmers and meat producers say that
isn't so the food supply chain they say
remains intact has been ramping up to
meet the unprecedented stockpiling
brought on by the coronavirus epidemic
even so shoppers can most likely expect
to see some empty shelves intermittently
as the nation's networks of food
producers distributors and retailers are
stretched as never before
industries calibrated to supply
consumers with just enough of what they
need on a given day cannot keep up with
a nationwide surge of relentless
shoppers basically there's a rush on
goods but folks don't freak out again as
long as you can as long as you have
enough food or enough resources to go
get takeout for the next 3-4 days then
you will be fine right you don't
actually need to stock up as much as
everybody people who are buying like
water bottles and freaking that about
okay the water supply is not getting
shut off guys if you have to rely on
your stock of water bottles we are so
screwed you ain't gonna live I mean if
they shut off the electricity in the
water that's a whole different sort of
thing and no one's talking about any of
that right if you're talking about
stocking up really should be stocking up
on meat right maybe some dairy products
like the stuff that has a shelf life but
the sort of panic buying of things like
water like water is the is the number is
the number three panic buying item don't
be an idiot okay water is not running
out guys it comes right from your tap
it's free right worst comes to people to
have water I understand buying rice and
dried beans right that makes some sense
by buying pasta right that make some
sense although again that stuff is is
gonna last on the shelves for a long
time but it's a it's it's fascinating to
watch as the sort of stuff that it'll be
okay right all that's gonna happen is
gonna be okay now it's not the grocery
stores that are learning to be in
trouble we're gonna get to the financial
ramifications to all of this in just one
second because the Dow Jones Industrial
Average had to pause again this morning
after the market dropped a thousand
points so we're gonna get to that
Cheerilee but first let's talk about
keeping your home safe and secure so
there are a few ramifications obviously
to coronavirus one of those
ramifications there are a lot of people
who are home and that means there are a
lot of people who don't have anything
better to do and there are a lot of
people who may be criminals for looking
around for things to do during this time
of doing nothing and that means that you
probably want your neighborhood to be
safe right what better time then now to
know exactly what is going on at your
property and this is why you need ring
devices I have been in favor of ring
devices for years I'm very paranoid
about my own security but paranoia is
just the first step in caution so go
check out ring calm right now
ring gives you protection at every
corner helps you create custom
affordable security for your home rings
video doorbells let you answer the door
and check in on your home anytime from
anywhere rings full home security
systems give you everything you need to
protect your family pets and property
with rings outdoor security cameras you
can check in on every part of your house
ring will detect motion when people come
onto your property and then you'll
receive notifications on your phone
tablet PC you can see here speak to
visitors in real time from anywhere this
happen to me many times where I know
that somebody is now at the front door I
know that somebody is approaching the
property and that gives me peace of mind
especially when I'm not at home got a
special offer on the ring welcome kit
when you go to ring calm / Ben right now
the ring welcome kit includes the ring
video doorbell - and chime Pro it's all
you need to start building custom
security for your home today just go to
ring comm / Ben that is ring comm / Ben
go check them out right now okay so as I
say obviously this is having significant
financial ramifications for everybody
and you're going to see the
entertainment industry hit really hard
you're gonna see the restaurant industry
hit really hard right now that means
jobs there now there's some economists
who believe that that we could lose
hundreds of thousands of jobs in the
month of March and in months of in the
month of April as people stop going out
as people stop purchasing as people stop
borrowing to start new businesses
basically the only things that are open
right now in a lot of major cities are
banks as well as groceries and
pharmacies the domestic box office just
saw a shellacking the domestic box
office posted its worst weekend in
nearly two decades I made calls to
practice social distancing to slow the
corona virus pandemic the box office
experienced its first weekend fully in
the throes of the virus outbreak grosses
in the u.s. in Canada total just 5350
5.3 million dollars plus all the
theaters in
our shut down and that is a major source
of wealth for Hollywood so Hollywood is
just getting crushed right now Hollywood
hit anticipated we ticket sales but they
not really anticipated that all of the
theaters would be shut down in major
cities which is what is currently
happening so the the dramatic reduction
in ticket in ticket sales is obviously
going to hurt
Hollywood the question for Sports is
what's gonna happen what will sports
really ever recover from this hiatus
we've already seen the NBA has basically
suspended the season March Madness has
been canceled the MLB is not even to
start its season the question is gonna
be how do you even recover from this
because six months from now is
coronavirus really gone is it still
hanging around the fringes are we gonna
want to get together in large crowds
ever again are the the sports that are
that are most likely to succeed gonna be
those that are basically made-for-tv all
of the economic costs are gonna be
billions and billions of dollars and we
had on my friend clay Travis
last week sports broadcaster that Jude
has a three hour sports radio show to
fill today like I don't even know what
he's gonna talk about how much can you
talk about who's the best center fielder
of all time can you do that for like
three hours a day forever how exactly is
that going to work so at some point
sports are gonna return but it's gonna
be a long road so in attempting to stop
all this the feds slashed its rates to
near zero and unveiled a new sweeping
program to aid the economy the central
bank cut rates by a full percentage
points and announced a giant bond buying
campaign to insulate the economy against
coronavirus fala basically the Federal
Reserve is now saying they're gonna buy
up some debt they're gonna buy up
mortgage debt they're gonna buy up
student loan debt they're gonna buy up a
bunch of debt in order to prevent people
from having those debts called in on
them and prevent for example a real
estate meltdown as banks losing money
from businesses closing down started
calling in mortgage debt instead the
government saying less and we'll back
the mortgage debt you don't have to
worry about it let people you know let
people survive right now put everything
on pause that makes some sense right
mean this is a global pandemic it will
come to an end at some point people will
go back to work there will be a recovery
what doesn't make a ton of sense to me
is the Fed dramatically lowering its
rates as though this is going to solve
the problem like they've now run out of
bullets there are no more bullets the
reason people aren't buying and and
borrowing right now has nothing like
literally nothing to do with the rates
of borrowing is
if you lower but this is the typical
theory behind the Fed lowering interest
rates is that you want people to borrow
you want a jog the economy so you lower
the interest rates to get people to
borrow but this is a misperception of
why people are not borrowing right now
nobody is borrowing right now because
who the hell is gonna borrow into this
economy you know borrow to start a
business right now
nobody is gonna do that gonna borrow to
buy a new house right now you can barely
pay the mortgage on the house that you
got hey bar lowering the interest I
think now's a good time to refight your
mortgage but lowering your interest rate
is not actually going to radically
change the status of the economy because
again there's an underlying issue here
and the underlying issue is fairly
obvious it's called the global pandemic
and nobody going to work ever again that
would be the global underlying issue
there's a big difference between that
and for example the stock market crash
of 1929 that was not brought on by an
actual real world event that jogged
everything to a complete and utter halt
right well this is not even by 2007-2008
where the banks had basically bet big on
the real estate market and then people
started being unable to pay back their
their subprime mortgages and the real
estate market collapsed in on itself
that was just banks making bad bets and
they should have had been forced to eat
the bad bets that's not what's happening
right now what's happening right now is
an external event and that external
shock is destroying the capacity of
businesses to operate so backing the
capacity of businesses to operate or at
least not lose their shirt right now
that makes some sense but lowering the
interest rates generally is not gonna
cause an uptick in the economy is I'm
gonna cause people to borrow and that's
why you're seeing the markets actually
that's got major hit this morning the
Dow Jones Industrial Average was down at
an early hour about 1700 points down
over 7% the market opens and immediately
had to shut for 15 minutes because of
the Dow Jones Industrial Average the
we're just gonna be going up and down
for a while here guys okay bottom line
is this is a yo-yo nobody knows where to
price the market nobody even knows how
bad this thing is gonna get and so in
the absence of knowing how bad this
thing is gonna get it's very difficult
to tell where the bottom is so I've been
saying for a while if you can afford to
buy and hold for a long period of time
now's not a bad time to buy I'm not
saying this is the bottom of the market
I don't know where the bottom of the
market is I know that in ten years this
is not where the bottom of the market is
going to be even in five years even in
three years even in two years I think
but with that said I can't say that this
is the very best time to buy right
Mohamed el-erian
friend of the program and the head of
Allianz
he suggested you know or encouraging
people to buy right now in this sort of
volatility is probably a mistake again
that's if you have to sell right if you
have extra liquidity now it's actually a
fairly good time to buy because if you
can buy and hold then you're never gonna
lose money on the market over broad
periods of time in addition to cutting
its benchmark interest rate by a full
percentage point returning it to a range
of 0 to 0.25 percent the Fed said it
would inject huge sums into the economy
by snapping up at least 500 billion
dollars of Treasury securities and at
least 200 billion dollars of
mortgage-backed debt over the coming
months that again makes perfect sense
because if you're backing the debt of
people's that the banks don't have to
call in that debt and remove people from
their homes for example foreclosure
rates and people people's house value
dropping that's a good thing for a short
term shock just to sort of insulate
against that that's not bailing out the
banks that is bailing out everybody but
if you are talking about spiking the
economy by somehow lowering the interest
rate that doesn't make any sense
President Trump praised the central bank
move sought to assure worried Americans
that food supplies would not be
disrupted President Trump who's been
stumping for a very long time about the
lowering of the interest rates but that
is sort of a bizarre again a sort of
bizarre reaction the problem here is not
the interest rates people are not
borrowing because they're not borrowing
and spiking interest rates to zero is
not actually going to cause be like
again who's gonna go out and take a loan
in this economy like anyone okay and
lowering the interest rates to zero
ain't gonna change a thing that does not
solve the underlying economic problem
but here was president Trump praising
the Fed for cutting interest rates to
zero he's been calling like if trumpet
had his way by the way we're noting it
from dad his way a year ago they with
this would have been at zero the federal
interest rate and then we would have no
bullets left in the chamber now we're
out of bullets so you really help very
much by the way worth noting we are so
irresponsible as a people we just are in
terms of our government we spend a
trillion dollars a year more than we
take in we spend trillions we spent
ourselves between sane debt what do you
think happens when a crisis hits and now
you actually have to take out debt we're
like the morons who went out and bought
a boat every single year and now the
wage earner and the family died and
they're like oh you know what would have
been smart not buying a boat every
single year because now we actually have
to take out some debt idiotic anyway
here's President from praising the Fed
for cutting raise to zero I want to
congratulate the Federal Reserve
for starters they've lowered the Fed
rate from what it was which was one to
1.25 and it's been lowered down to zero
to 0.25 that's really good news it's
really great for our country it's
something that we're very happy I have
to say this up very happy and they did
it in one step that into it in four
steps over a long period of time they
did it in one step and I think that
people in the market should be very
thrilled I will say this president from
Surry down the market not accurate my
friends not accurate over the last two
weeks he was like the markets gonna be
fine and now he's like yeah people in
the market will be thrilled he said this
yesterday there was only one problem the
market immediately opened down eight
percent had a shut for 15 minutes and is
currently not almost 2000 points so ya
know on that no on that it turns out
that the Presidents read on the Fed is
not an accurate read on the federal K
we're gonna get to more on the on the
global economy and the and the economic
recovery that may follow after all of
this we can hope and then we will get to
more of president Trump's
administration's policy we'll get to the
debate between Joe Biden Bernie Sanders
that no one cares about last night but
two oldies demonstrating that they
should not be anywhere near the levers
of power we get so all that interest
second first let's talk about people at
your company who you may not need
anymore now right now is an excellent
time to make sure that your employees
keep getting paid frankly I mean this is
a great time to hunker down make sure
that the people who you love the people
who who you need are still making a
living right if you can do that that's
great but if you are looking for
somebody better than say a person who
comes back to the office having been
exposed to coronavirus and then just
blithely waltzes into the office and
just proceeds to take off his shirt you
know like really enjoy himself like a
michael moles type well then maybe you
need to look at zip recruiter com if you
need to find the best candidates for
your growing business zip recruiter is
you're smart efficient hiring solution
zip broker makes hiring great people
faster and easier today you can try zip
recruiter for free at zip recruiter comm
slash at daly wire when you head over to
zip recruiter with one click you send
your job as zip recruiters network of
over 100 leading job sites what happens
next well zip recruiter finds the best
matches for your job and invites them to
apply it's so effective that four out of
five employers who post on the zip
recruiters you get a quality candidate
within the very first day so if you're
looking to replace that employers been
bugging you for a while now is a good
time to do it over at zip recruiter tom
and daily wire that is zip recruiter
dot-com / Dai ly Wira zip recruiter comm
/ daily wire zip recruit is indeed the
smartest way to hire go check them out
right now
okay other news while so many of us are
driven to isolation right now it is
really important more important than
ever I think that we come together as a
community particularly online the good
news is we are an Internet company at
the Daily wire we want to do everything
we can to help our members through this
difficult time we can hang out together
in our reporting we're making sure we
bring you facts and we always do so so
you can understand the situation you can
properly prepare in addition to keeping
informed we also want to help our
members take their minds off the stress
of the situation and so we're launching
something that we're accelerating the
launch of a new show called all-access
live Jeremy boring and I we're gonna
host the first live episode tonight at 5
p.m. Pacific 8 p.m. Eastern don't worry
we're safe both of us
we're I'm he's not gonna give me Corona
I'm not gonna give him Corona we're not
us experiencing symptoms we are working
on additional programming for this week
as I speak we want to hang out with you
I understand listen I I remember being
in law school okay at Harvard Law and I
remember the long winters being alone in
my dorm basically we are now all me and
law school hanging out alone in our dorm
and nothing is comforting as quite as
being part of a community online we want
this show to give you all a chance to
hang out with us and each other we're
gonna discuss things outside of the
current news we're gonna talk like
religion and movies and yes we'll do the
best centerfielders ever every day level
we're just gonna hang out because I know
like now is a great time for us all that
we can't hang out in person but we can't
hang out online as we do anyway so why
not expand that so that you can actually
you know get off the schnide a little
bit and just spend some time with us the
show is intended for our all-access
members during the national emergency
and time of isolation we're opening up
to all of our members we're gonna get
through this we're gonna be stronger as
a nation and as a community when we do I
really think that you know we have to
socially we have to physically distance
we don't have to socially distance I
hope that you can join me this evening
at 5 p.m. Pacific 8 p.m. Eastern
remember all of our members are able to
watch the livestream and livestream and
join live chat we are a community we
want to hang out with you it was
actually my personal suggestion I would
like to I think is really important we
all hang out together so let's do this
thing tonight 5 p.m. Pacific 8 p.m.
Eastern we'll see you then go check us
out a daily where I can't become a
member remember you don't have to be an
all-access member right now you may have
to later but right now we're opening up
to all of our members of all levels so
go check us out right now over a daily
wire.com we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so again the the Fed is a band-aid on a
gaping wound the New York Times reports
investors were confronted with weak
economic readings out of China and the
United States Chinese officials reported
that retail sale sales manufacturing
activity and investment in the first two
months of the year had slumped even more
than economists expected a gauge
manufacturing activity in New York State
collapsed by the most ever in history in
a month economic analysts with the
investment bank Jefferies in New York
said unfortunately this is the new
reality this report is a harbinger of
what is to come European markets also
tanked on Monday falling more than 6%
france's main stock index fell briefly
by 10% the moves were intended to ensure
that credit flows freely spurring
businesses and households to continue
borrowing and spending but again that's
idiotic nobody's actually gonna borrow
and spend in this economy
the notion that the Fed was going to
solve this thing the Fed is firing the
federal 'its at a miasma that's not
going to work
that's not the way any of this works
meanwhile the House has passed a
sweeping coronavirus response package
it's got some good stuff and some bad
stuff as per usual with our government
that that included a bipartisan vote to
expand access to free testing which of
course is good providing a billion
dollars in food aid and extending sick
leave benefits to vulnerable Americans
one of the big problems with extending
sick leave benefits to vulnerable
Americans without government backing is
that is a pretty good way to bankrupt
small businesses that are operating
right at the margins it's easy to say
that small businesses should basically
keep taking the hit when they're not
getting any income but what happens when
all of those small business have small
businesses have to declare bankruptcy I
literally talked to a friend of mine who
runs a business yesterday he does major
catering and an event business and he
said to me like I may have to declare
bankruptcy I said to him okay well if
you do and then everything gets back on
track I'm always here to give you a loan
like really I think that people should
help each other out if they have the
resources to do so but the you know
legislation that forces small businesses
to cover paid sick leave that's all fun
and games until it turns out that you're
talking about small businesses that have
like 75 employees like more than 50 have
75 employees and now they're expected to
pay indefinite sick leave for people for
what weeks at a time even if the
business has to shut down and and by the
way I don't believe there's any time
limit on that I think that the Democrats
were able to pass this thing without a
sunset provision which means that even
if coronavirus end that would still be
the case alongside Pelosi major Majority
Leader Steny Hoyer said he expected the
House Committee
be working through next week's recess on
a new bill meant to address the economic
damage wrought by corona virus which has
devastated the airline hospitality and
entertainment industries Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy said I think this is a
very good sign of bipartisanship and
working together that we can overcome
the virus and president Trump's approval
of the bill was forthcoming via Twitter
key Republicans caution they're still
lingering issues related to a tax credit
for paid at family sick leave McCarthy
wants small businesses to have a little
bit more flexibility because right now
there is no flexibility in the rules one
of the major obstacles involved the
president's personal demand for a
payroll tax cut in the package Democrats
were not willing to go along with that
further actions are likely to be taken
in the near future the legislation helps
provide free food for children whose
schools are closed during the crisis as
well as other initiatives to make sure
the seniors and food banks get help as
well and one of the problems with the
the free school lunch program of course
is that you might be better off just
giving the family's food directly right
you may instead of the extending the
free school lunch programs which by the
way have been a fairly large-scale
failure across the United States in
terms of the amounts of food that's been
thrown away maybe you'd be better off
just giving the Andrew yang thousand
dollar tax credit right just give
everybody a thousand bucks for the
moment in order to get through this
crisis I mean you're effectively doing
that with businesses anyway the
legislation included 14 paid sick days
for employees as well as three months of
paid emergency leave three months of
paid emergency leave like I don't know
how they expect businesses to weather
that three months of paid emergency
leave who's gonna pay for that employers
will be reimbursed for some of the costs
through tax credits okay good luck with
that at the GOP insistence the emergency
leave provision expires in year the paid
sick days do not expire in a year but
the very small businesses are being
exempted from the requirements but if
you got 75 employees that's not a
massive business you're not being
exempted from any of this so again not a
very good bill but this is the way that
we do legislation in the United States
we don't actually tailor the remedy to
the actual problem meanwhile the the
White House was praising the bill Mike
Pence said this bipartisan deal is gonna
help take care of those who need to
here's the vice president yesterday deal
that passed the House last night we'll
head to the Senate early next week next
week delivers on the president's plan
for strong health and
support particularly focused on those
most impacted including hard-working
blue-collar Americans who may not
currently have paid family leave today
it provides free coronavirus testing for
uninsured Americans and it builds on the
decisions of President Trump made
expanding coverage for Medicare Medicaid
and also getting a commitment from
private health insurance companies to
join with us to waive all co-pays on
coronavirus testing okay so everybody's
very happy about the bill we will see
you know what the cost is but again we
could afford to be irresponsible with a
bill like this if we had not spent the
last I don't know forty years building
up a twenty two trillion dollar debt you
meanwhile scott Gottlieb who's been one
of the kind of darker voices of doom and
that's not say he's inaccurate just
means that he's got a pretty dark vision
of what's gonna happen here with
coronavirus the former FDA head under
President Trump he says the White House
is on top of this the federal response
is now appropriate to the situation I've
been fortunate to have the opportunity
to talk to officials in the White House
all through this some of the calls that
I was making to the conversations I was
having go back to January
they've been on top of this I mean
they've been concerned about this I've
been talking to White House staff and
the staffs been concerned about this
okay deborah birx
is saying something similar although she
is saying that the cases are going to
spike now notice when we follow the
numbers of course the cases are gonna
spike part of the reason the cases are
gonna spike some of that is gonna have
to do with presumably the exponential
growth of a virus but part of that is
gonna have to do with increased testing
so do not be alarmed by the mere spike
in growth note that that the testing is
lagging it has been lagging so as the
testing becomes more common the feds are
now saying there should be up to 4,000
tests a day it's gonna quickly escalate
from there with more tests come more
positives and that means that you're
going to see a spike in the number of
cases in the United States do not be
surprised by that do not necessarily be
alarmed by that if it continues to be
exponential after we've taken all of
these measures then we can start being
like supremely alarmed but Debra Burke
says yeah there will be spikes in cases
so you will notice as these tests roll
out over this next week we will have a
spike in our curve for those of you who
watched China and China reporting
remember when they change their
definition and all of a sudden there was
a
up in there curve we are going to see
that we are going to see a spike as more
and more people have access meanwhile
Anthony Falchi he says listen possible
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people could die of coronavirus hey that
sort of information is not supremely
useful I mean sure that's possible what
are the chances can we get like a can we
get like some sort of bell curve on what
are the chances of that is that like an
outlying estimate is that an in lying
estimate like what's the data based on I
understand he's on TV and he's getting
sound bytes and I understand he wants us
all to take this seriously but more
information would be good more
transparency would be good here's dr.
Anthony foul she'd the head of the
National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases
there been estimates of hundreds of
thousands of people in the US who could
die or in the worst-case scenario
millions can you tell the American
people that that is possible you know
it's possible because when you do a
model you have a worst case scenario the
best case scenario and the reality is
how you react to that will depend where
you're going to be on that curve so
obviously we are clearly going to have
more infections there's going to be more
problems it with regard to morbidity and
mortality okay so we really don't have
the full information but the point that
foul she was making is he's saying
listen do everything that you can
he says dramatic reduction in
interactions would be what is called for
here I basically stopped interacting
with people for the foreseeable future
here's vouching yesterday on state of
the union would you like to see a
national lockdown basically people you
can't go out to restaurants bars you
need to stay home well I would like to
see a dramatic diminution of the
personal interaction that we see in
restaurants and in bars whatever it
takes to do that that's what I'd like to
see okay he continues along these lines
and he says that the travel bans were a
good idea despite the media's hatred for
the travel bans here's dr. pouchy again
the president's decision to to
essentially have a major blocking of
travel from China that already had an
effect of not ceding the way in Europe
Italy didn't do that and my I feel so
badly because I have so many friends
there they're getting hit hard what
we're doing now with the other travel
restrictions
so you block infections from coming in
and then within is when you have
containment and mitigation and that's
the reason why the kinds of things we're
doing that may seem like an overreaction
will keep us away from that worst-case
scenario yeah well none of this has
stopped all of this from becoming
political obviously it was going to
become political with with Congress
finally passing some bills maybe they'll
shut up for the moment but the the
continuation of the Democratic
presidential race means that this is
going to continue being quite political
the Democrat debate last night took
place basically in an empty room between
Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders I'm sure
the ratings were abysmal nobody wants to
watch a democratic debate in the middle
of this watch to octogenarians going at
a clubbing each other with their with
their walkers honestly Bernie Sanders
has no more opportunity to win in this
race they're canceling primaries as we
speak by the way so it's not even as
though Bernie has the maybe Bernie gets
lucky and you know Biden retires because
he's obviously not fully functional but
that is highly unlikely this point
suffice it to say it is not a great
thing that all of the candidates for
president of the United States are in
the coronaviruses sweet spot hey Joe
Biden is old with underlying health
conditions Bernie Sanders is old with
underlying health conditions Donald
Trump is old enough condition none of
this is a recipe for greatness here the
democratic debate last night began with
elbow bumping and coughing which is
always a great sign to America I here
are the two Democratic candidates last
night do they keep this social isolation
thing right was that elbow thrown at the
jaw of Bernie Sanders by Joe Biden what
do you say to the American people who
are confronting this new reality first
of all my heart goes out to those who
have already lost someone or those who
are suffering from the virus okay so
that's all these good news Joe Biden was
confident fair but last night neither
Bernie nor Biden by the way it looked
like they were fully functional mentally
and they're each making the kinds of
mistakes you make when you're 80 years
old I mean that's that's not because
they're they're dumb or anything that's
just the way that it works with all that
said the politicization here is not
going to stop the the Trump
surgeongeneral he told the reporters
yesterday guys like for the moment can
we cut it with like the retrospective
criticism like just for a moment you can
always do this later like just wait two
weeks if you're trying to solve a
problem like in the here and now that's
one thing but if you're just bitching
something that happened seven weeks ago
the Trump said maybe you ought to put
that aside for like the next five
minutes while we try and get a response
together I want you all to understand
some straight talk from the nation's
doctor we really need you all to lean
into and prioritize the health and
safety of the American people no more
bickering no more partisanship no more
criticism or finger-pointing there'll be
plenty of time for that but we all need
to hit the reset button and lean into
moving forward the health and safety of
the American people are their top
priority more stories on how people can
protect themselves more people on how
people can get the resources that they
need that we've Unleashed from the
federal government and state and local
governments les stories looking at what
happened in the past again there'll be
time for that okay that is dr. jerome
adams and he's being ripped up and down
by the media who are saying well we're
going to cover the same of course you're
gonna cover this any way you want the
question is are you keeping your eye on
the ball which is making the coverage
making the the response better or is
this really more about political
posturing and that remains I would tear
remains to be seen except I think that
the last few weeks have proved that it
doesn't remain to be seen I think it's
pretty obvious that the media do have a
rooting interest in these screw-ups of
the Trump administration that's not
saying that they want to see something
that happened in Americans it's just
saying they they are not unhappy went
from messes things up alrighty we're
gonna get to some things that I like and
some things that I hate so things that I
like so you're gonna have some time on
your hands if you like sports but all
the sports are off the TV the TV
let me just recommend the greatest
baseball book ever in history it is the
new Bill James historical baseball
abstract it hasn't been updated for
quite a while but it is just fantastic
basically he ranks every player pretty
much ever brings like the top hundred
players in on each positions if you're a
baseball fan this thing is like the
ultimate bathroom book it is just
fantastic on every level bill James of
course revolutionized the game of
baseball by focusing so much on
statistics and looking for new
statistical ways to measure exactly who
was good and who was not it was Bill
James who came up with a lot of the key
statistics that we now use as opposed to
the old-fashioned statistics like we
used to focus a lot on batting average
now everybody of course focuses on
on-base percentage we should focus a lot
on batting average now people focus on
on slugging percentage right on base
plus slugging is a better gauge of how
good a player is than simple batting out
because if you get a lot of hits but you
don't walk ever that may not actually be
the best the the new bill Jim's
historical baseball abstract is just
something and get lost in four hours and
you're gonna have some hours on your
hands unless you have kids unless you
have kids in which case you're basically
screwed let me just point out that all
of my heart my heart goes out to people
who are single and stuck at home for
this whole thing my heart also goes out
as a parent my heart goes out to all the
people who are just told that they now
have to homeschool their kids for the
next two months and suddenly have become
teachers who cannot set up playdates
with their kids and other kids can't
take their kids to play gyms can't take
their kids to the park because of all
the equipment over there and basically
have now been relegated to little a
little house on the prairie style
parenting for the foreseeable future so
shout-out to my wife who's now dealing
with this at home as we speak and and
good for good for all of you for doing
what you can to make sure that your kids
have a fulfilling experience during this
time people have been asking me what I
say to my kids in in the middle of all
of this and when I say to my kids is
listen everything is gonna be fine and
basically you get early summer vacation
the big problem you just have to hang
out with us so yeah I think I think
it'll be honestly my kids are kind of
excited about it they're more excited
about it then I think any parents are at
this point but don't worry we're all
hanging in together no quick reminder
tonight we are gonna be doing some extra
programming just for our members over at
daily wire calm normally this would be
all access kind of stuff but any of our
members now get access to it we're gonna
be broadcasting live at 5 p.m. Pacific 8
p.m. Eastern so that we can all get
through this together we're gonna try
and do a little bit extra programming in
the evenings so you have something to do
and a community to gather with online so
go check us out over at daily where I
begin out it's a great time become a
member go check us out right now over at
daily wire otherwise we'll be here for
two hours later today and we'll be back
here tomorrow to recap everything as
it's going on stay safe out there take
care of your family go for a walk make a
call to a friend make sure everybody's
doing ok we're gonna get through it
together we're here with you every
single day see you in a little bit i'm
ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by micro Amina hair and makeup
is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2025 hey everybody its Andrew
clave and host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]